ん
的でありますありがとうございます
みなさんこんにちは
清水陽子です
生物化学出身の現代芸術家立つ
私のラボではアートと科学を融合した
インスタレーションを制作しています
さまざまな自然や科学的な現象を取り上げ
ています
多くの方はアートと科学何の関係があるの
と思われるかもしれませんでも私にとって
はアートと科学はとても似ていて両方とも
非常にクリエイティブな分野で
新しいアイデアを探求し常識の壁を
打ち破るものです
大学のラボでは
化学と生物学を専攻していました
科学の減速や
減少やフォルムの美しさに心を奪われまし
たそして思ったのです
私たちの取り巻くこれらの無数の自然の細
コア後に使ったらどんなに素敵だろうと
これらの不変の原則は
人類が存在する前から存在し今後もずっと
存在し続けるものです
これらの法則や理論は目には見えないもの
がたくさんありますですので以下に可視化
していくかがポイントとなります
可視化することで
こういった素晴らしいことを体験すること
をがアートとして体験することができます
はい
今日はいくつか
イースターレーションで使っているパーツ
を持ってきました
大型のインスてレーションとして展示
ホールの大きさに合わせて大量オフ生産し
ているものですではこれを見てください
これは
重力に逆らうというインスタレーション
です
シャンデリアのように
試験管
に水を入れてフタをせずに吊り下げます
逆さにしても試験官の水はこぼれません
表面張力や大気圧の助けでバランスが取れ
ているからです
それではこの試験管で試してみましょう
まず水を入れます
今日は
少々インクを入れて
遠くからも見えるようにしてみます
水を入れて
逆さにします
の悪いてい
水はこぼれません
一度安定するとこのまま水は下から蒸発し
て最後には空っぽになります
展示ホールでは天井に天井から下げます
そして水明を下から見上げることができ
ます
それは日常では経験できない神秘的な光景
です二つ目は真ん中にありますけれども
シャボン玉の幾何学立体ですシャボン玉と
いうとみなさん球体を思い浮かべると思い
ます
球体になるのはそれが
最小の表面積だからです
もし
科学的なフォルムによってフレームによっ
てその形をコントロールしたらどうなる
でしょう
ではこれでやってみましょう
これは正四面体ですね
シャボンの溶液につけます
鋭いさん関係が中心に向かってできます
可愛いですよね
太陽光があれば
虹色の光も見えるところですが
中にちょっとだけ空気を入れると
ミニチュアのシムん四面体が出来上がり
ます
これもた陽光の下では非常にきれいに光る
んです
この形は長い間保つこともできます
これが
最小の表面積だからこういう形になるん
です
様々な幾何学の立体の形によって様々な
シャボン玉の形を作ることができます
無限の可能性があります
私はいつも自然が
正確で美しい形を瞬時に
作り出すこと計算もせずにできることに
いつも感動しています
最後のパーツはアクアソニックリミックス
からのものです
オーディオ椅子てレーションでん
音波を水のなみっとして可視化するもの
です
そもそもウトって何でしょう
音は派
空気の振動です
私の今話している音も
空気を振動させています
最終的に細くに到達してそれが脳におとー
として認識させます
ただ私たちは空気や振動を見ることができ
ませんでも水は見ることができます
ですので音を見ずに対応させるという
美しい波を水面上で見ることができます
波が見れますか
水が時々跳ねて
波も形を変えます
音也
波長が変わるによってこの動きも変わり
ます
高いピッチの
音だと波が星のように小さな花たちに
変わります
音が低くなると大きな波に変わります
ね跳ね飛ぶ水の量も少なくなります
ようなんyou are
こうして世の中が全く新しい世界に見えて
きたと思います
私たちが話してる間にも振動している空気
地面へと引きつける重力
360度の大気圧
引っ張り合う水星4
こういった美しい現象がたくさん起こって
いるのです
ブレイクする起こしたいときアートや科学
だけではなくて日常生活や仕事でも
自分たちを解放してまったく新しい世界へ
とのを開くことが必要です
見回してみると私たちの周りは
インスピレーションであふれています
恐れずに
まったく正反対に思えるような物や考えを
組み合わせてみてくださいなぜならそこに
新しく美しい刷毛があるからですアートと
科学のように
ありがとうございます